who would you say today
in america if you were to say the most
influential
person in america that follows and would
like to
aspire one day for america to be what
karl marx talks about in his book
communism
communist manifesto who would aspire to
see america become that if you were to
say
big name not small name big names well
that's a good question i mean for that
sort of hardcore
you'd have to go to like communist party
usa website is cpusa.org
you'd have to go to like the trotskyist
socialist workers party
the the editors at the people's world
which is peoplesworld.org
that's the successor to the daily worker
there's a guy named
bob avakian who runs the revolutionary
communist party
um revcom they're known as bob ovakian
about armenian yeah i that's a good
question it probably is armenian
yeah a v a k i a n
um if you look it up bob ovakian they
call him
chairman bob and he's got at his website
his website revcom
revolutionary communist party usa is all
about
him so do you see it yeah
yeah that's him he is armenian by the
way is an american armenian
american lawyer civil rights activist
and later judge on alameda
county uh california superior court
interesting
yeah so he he's he's a leader and
he is when you saw last summer or last
year patrick
that communist party endorses joe biden
for president
i remember i saw i got that email
immediately because of who i am right in
my email box and i thought
wow that's weird communist party usa i
know that they're for biden and for the
democrat every
four years but they don't usually
endorse him because that hurts the
the endorsement hurts so i clicked that
it wasn't communist party usa it was
it was chairman bob it was bob ovakian
he's the one that endorsed biden
for that is he is he a guy that debates
and gets on different platforms and
interviews or no
i don't think he does much from what i
can tell he's mostly solo
and and posts for a while he was in
exile
and possibly in paris and i have often
wondered if it was a
self-imposed exile well we'll definitely
reach out to them because we've had
slavo and jizya khan and we've had
uh professor richard wolfon and a few
other guys on so i'm always curious to
know
to speak to them so okay so i think is
it fair to say that
the topic of communism is not creating a
lot of momentum
in u.s at all it's not like it's gonna
one day be a threat to u.s
again like it was back in the days under
reagan well here's the threat and here
i think is the longer answer to your
question the people today who are
sympathetic to communism are calling
themselves democratic socialists
and and so if there's a kind of leader
for that today first of all there's
bernie sanders okay
and bernie sanders was a formal
presidential elector
to the socialist workers party in 1980
and 1984.
so 1980 when most normal americans are
deciding whether to vote vote between
carter or reagan right bernie sanders
was supporting the trotskyist socialist
workers party
we've never found proof that bernie
um was an actual member of the socialist
workers party
but you look in his background he's long
been a supporter of it and probably knew
better
than to actually formally join it daniel
greenfield of frontpagemagazine.com
david horowitz's freedom center
ron radosh look up their writings on
bernie's time
in a stalinist kibbutz in israel
in the early 1960s so bernie was way to
the far left
bernie was never a democrat until 2016
when he sought the democratic party's
nomination
he was an independent um james carville
right said
bernie's not a democrat why is he
running as a democrat he's not even a
dem he's not he's not a democrat
but he came in second for the democratic
party presidential nomination in 2016
and 2020.
bernie's a lifetime socialist but but
one more thing
the trotskyist socialist workers party
they published the publication the
militant
and the militant you can look up online
lee harvey oswald the assassin of jfk
holding the rifle in one hand that he
shot jfk with and a copy of the militant
newspaper in the other hand it's been
around for a long time
the other leaders of the sort of modern
socialism the democratic socialism as
they call it
it's the democratic socialists of
america that's the group
that's it patrick that is it communist
party usa
says that they've had a membership surge
where they're now at about 5 000 members
all right that sucks right the
democratic socialists of america
are are in a true membership surge and
are now up to about 90
000 altogether and their poster girl
is alexandria ocasio-cortez and the
other one
in fact they have poster girls it's the
squad
um ilhan omar who i think is
the most radical member of the house and
the third one is rasheeda
tulabe who who said of donald trump we
need to impeach the mother
you know blank and the fourth one is
eliana presley although i don't think
presley
is is an actual democratic socialist but
she's part of the squad
so that's really that's where the
momentum is today
so if you if you look up democratic
socialists online look up look up
democratic socialists of america
um annual convention communist
international
and they're they're singing the the the
international
at the start of their at the start of
their convention and calling each other
comrades
right so they uh they'll say oh we're
not
communists we're not even socialists
we're democratic socialists
but but when you hear the rhetoric and
see what they say and you see what they
read
like richard pipes said you know there's
no meaningful distinction between
socialism and communism
oftentimes there's indeed not so if you
like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you